no we got some big news actually this
news is from yesterday
uh heidi hatch from kutvs confirmed a
utah man involved in the protests
uh this uh of all the presidents in utah
this spring was in dc and stormed the
capital amid violent protests
is a man named john sullivan and he was
arrested as a member of black lives
matter during during the riots in spring
and apparently he claims he was there
just to document
but he was there as the woman was shot
so it looks like we do have confirmation
of leftists
part of the protests that stormed the
capitol building
i brought this up you know as a lot of
people are saying like matt gates said
there's a facial recognition company
that found antifa or something i don't
think that's true i think they denied
that
i don't know where he got that
information from but a lot of people are
saying this was antifa who did this
well there's not a whole lot of evidence
but we we do have a guy now we have him
that's what i was wondering we were
asking some questions the other day
antifa always counter protests they
always show up they announced they were
going to show up where were they this
time
and so i said this a few days before now
that
the proud boys and trump supporters are
mad at cops what happens when antifa
says okay
and then they don't okay my enemy of my
enemy is my friend i guess
is that is it possible that some of
these people at least well we got this
from heidi hatch of kutv i believe she's
of kutv
yes kutv news confirming this guy
he's listed as an organizer of of the
provo protest arrested accused of
rioting and making threats
and they even say in the uh kutv story
or the woman she says
he does not align with donald trump uh
uh politically so we have leftists that
were inside the capitol
at least we can say that much i don't
know what that means moving forward but
and that's
that's what i think why i always just
say the term protesters
i mean i know people always get mad oh
it's a riot or it's this or it's that
i mean i just think that's a generic
term as opposed to saying
antifa blm rioters you don't know just
cause they're wearing all black
you know they could have come out there
with good intentions they're just a mom
who you know
wanted to you know her kid got beat up
by the police you know
so you don't know just because they're
wearing black or just because they're
wearing a red hat
oh okay yeah you support all the
president's policies this is where i i
don't care for the tribalism
that when that dude and all black showed
up to that was an auto zone or whatever
in minneapolis and smashing things out
immediately said that immediately they
said this guy is far right
like the left knew or a cop or or a cop
right
now we have the exact same thing when
this goes down
they're saying it was antifa who did
this and it's like there may be we've
got this we got this guy right
so this is from yesterday they're saying
they confirmed it but come on man there
were people wearing trump hats
we'll get we'll get a lot more
information as we see who does get
arrested
right because they do have fake facial
recognition in there right inside the
capitol
i don't know about well we have a whole
track trace and database society with
the nsa and fbi pretty much knowing
everything about everyone through their
cell phone they could easily geo-locate
everyone they don't need to put out
these uh you know
these notifications like the fbi in the
usa today
they released saying if you have any
information notify us send us all your
photos
send us all your tips send us all the
information we're going to go after
everyone
that was inside of there and again we
also another important element to kind
of really think about here
from my experience covering events mob
mentality is also something that people
really need to consider because yes
there are some bad bad actors but
there's also some people just caught up
in the crowd
there's one famous photo i just sent it
to you lydia of this like
older lady with her juice box literally
just
kind of like not knowing where she is
and uh yeah she was really getting like
walked down the steps by by capitol
police
yeah mike cernovich had an interesting
kind of uh
comment about this uh let me try to find
it here because
um what was he talking about he said
let's just say
this is after donald trump's
announcement he said let's just say that
the trump campaign will not be creating
a bail fund for his supporters
lots of innocent people gonna get caught
up i feel deep sadness for them
some bad guys sure but droves always
find
themselves in the nest this is this is a
really
sorry a common tactic we see among
left-wing organizers
first thing i'll say is i'm not saying
this as an attack outright on the left
i'm just pointing out the right is not
organized they're not
there's no like there's there's very
little organization on the right they
don't go out
it was not organized this whole thing
was poorly organized no bail support no
masks no plans no strategy
but among the left what they do is they
know who their marks are
it's like body filler essentially they
need a certain number of bodies as cover
and they want regular people to get
arrested so what we've seen in the past
is
you'll get like 10 extremist activists
or extremists
and they'll set up an event that's
palatable to a thousand regular people
who want to wave little flags
and say you know save the environment
once they get that march going
they use that as cover to go and
do some kind of action that results in a
mass arrest
that way when these hundred or thousand
regular people are confused
and getting arrested you get a bunch of
press they want that to happen
imagine if 10 people stormed the capital
just 10. people would be like oh 10
people went in i guess whatever
were they arrested yeah i guess you know
it would have been really easy for the
cops to handle it
so they know they need bodies
unsuspecting
doting you know individuals who have no
idea what's going on
who see an open door and walk in
confused bewildered and then the people
who are pushing for this who want it to
happen
can get away with it and it's and i'm
not saying that it was on purpose here
i'm just saying
what you end up seeing is often
unsuspecting and bewildered
it's a very marching psychological
phenomenon of like a mob
mentality yeah if a couple people do it
that's all it takes across the country
you can even see from the footage too
because right when folks are in there
they're just like like richie said they
were taking selfies smoking pot so
even for them they were more shocked
that they were even in there they were
just kind of taking it in they didn't
know
whether they were you know staging a
sit-in or you know or
occupying the capitol building for
several hours you know they didn't even
know they were you know
i was watching that you know a bunch of
streamers just having fun
smoking pot it was kind of a it was kind
of like that's what i'm saying this
if if that's antifa then i mean yeah i
mean
wow yeah i don't think any antifa is
going to dress as undercover trump
supporters he didn't want to go to jail
for ten years
to smoke a joint inside a capital but
whatever that trump put in place yeah
the idea that antifa would take their
mask off put on a mag take their mask
off put on a maga hat and then walk in
and be like i'm actually a trump
supporter here's my face
like they wouldn't do that yeah but
they're worse there were a lot of people
wearing masks
i saw some of these people and i thought
to myself trump sports don't go around
wearing masks like that
i've been to so many different trump
rallies you've got troublemakers that
are not left wing but there's also
boogaloo
boy types they wear masks you know so we
don't necessarily know who these people
were
again we do know one of these guys was a
blm
activist from utah who was there at the
capitol not surprised
we've seen those videos of black lives
matter and boogaloo boys shaking hands
you see that one yeah
the auntie of a guy's like you stood
here with us today so we're we thank you
like and then the boogaloo boy says
something like hey man like we agree the
government's bad
and they're like all right well they
agree you know so they like to claim
that boogaloo boys are somehow
the same as trump supporters it's just
not true it's not true
trump supporters are very much like
liberals
you know and not not politically of
course but in the sense that they like
the country to a certain degree you know
like they're okay with how this country
functions
they're okay with uh it's basically like
reform versus revolution
you've got extremists on both sides who
want dramatic change overhauling
revolution
and then you've got the regular left and
right wing individuals
and the problem is the left in this
country has moved so far
left but also gains has so much control
now of institutions
that regular trump supporters who
probably would be satisfied with winning
an election
are now feeling just totally cut out
period and so
you then start seeing you know i think
they're going to take advantage of that
that anger they have now will be used by
more extremist types including antifa
who was
clearly those who do they're from blm
well and we saw what happened in the
first the very first rally
uh basically there were tons of footage
of people in red hats walking through
blm plaza
similar situation didn't realize what
they were walking themselves into with
all like a
mass of blm folks in the plaza getting
their butts beat
and then the next time around the proud
boys say not this time and they all
travel from around the country by
literally the thousands and show up
ready to roll
and that time i mean i think there was a
lot more of the aggression coming from
the proud boys yeah we've got some huge
news
betsy devos has resigned writing in a
letter to the president
there is a quote there is no mistaking
the impact your rhetoric had on the
situation
and it is the inflection point for me oh
she was a staunch reporter too
staunch supporter and not only that but
she was
you know a lot of trump you know we have
jack murphy on the show and he talks
about democrat to deplorable he wrote
this book
he interviewed a lot of people and one
of the big issues was title ix right
reform from these colleges
making sure due process was standing and
and these critical critical race
theories being challenged
and she was very much doing that that's
what you know
trump brought her in for referral some
of the one of the reasons at least
now she's out i tell you man what
happened at that capitol you know you
know what man look there are a lot of
people that don't listen to me
the life doesn't want to listen for sure
and many of them staunches trump
supporters don't want to hear it
but when lynn woods snapped off i said
this is bad when sydney powell snapped
off this is bad
tucker carlson said i called city said
where's the evidence and she didn't give
us any and what happened his ratings got
cut
in half if you listened to tucker
trump would be in a better position
right now when i said
lynnwood is tweeting like crazy and is
one of the most destructive things for
the president
i had a bunch of just like ardent trump
supporting people say you're wrong he
knows what he's talking about like no
dude
whether that's true or not doesn't
matter okay fine i think it i think he's
he's he's off
i think he's gone nuts i don't know
what's going on with him but he's
delegitimizing
the president and so when all this goes
down you need to understand
the impact that going into that capital
had it scared people
nobody wants to be it's just
what do you accomplish exactly i don't i
don't see
what goal would you would have where
that's like a good way to get there
people thought that i guess
you know uh there's that video of that
woman and she's crying and she's like i
went in and they amazed me
and they're like why did you go in and
she goes we're starting the capital it's
a revolution like what do you mean a
revolution
you a bunch of random people walking
into the capitol building
is a revolution like um that's not you
know it's not what's kind of the saddest
thing too that we
should just take away is you know ashley
the the air force veteran who died
i mean she served our country she served
in wars only
to die in the u.s capitol building
i mean it's just a disgrace the people
in this country
are getting really mad and you know i'm
hearing people say
that it's a reminder to you know the
republican party or whatever
that that you know we're we're here and
we're allowed or whatever and i'm like
the republican party just like does what
the democrats want them to do for the
most part
they they feign objection they fain you
know oh we're gonna fight back and then
they obstruct and then nothing really
happens
like lindsey graham coming out and
saying like oh that's it for me i'm like
oh come on
like as if you were really ever doing
anything for anybody come on you
these politicians win because people go
and vote for r or d
not a person you know so what i've been
warning for some time is
you got a lot of angry people in this
country for a lot of reasons before
trump it was the loss of manufacturing
jobs and the collapse of these small
towns and the opioid crisis
and trump was addressing that in many
many different ways whether he solved
those problems another question
now with the covet lockdown a lot of
this is being revived and people are
angry
and they're especially mad now that the
president they supported after 74
million votes
loses but they're particularly mad that
there's a bunch of signed
sworn affidavits of impropriety and it
should be adjudicated and
and there's weird uh mathematical
anomalies and questions that want to be
raised
all of these things need to be presented
now
here here's the thing they talk about on
the in the media oh it went to court
these things were in court and they were
all you know shot down by the judges
well
not on the merits right on procedure
here's the problem
you actually had advocates in the senate
they call them the dirty dozen because
the media was insulting them the
republicans who said we are going to go
through the evidence
it was your chance to have the evidence
presented in the joint session exactly
and what happened they broke the doors
in they evacuated
and that was it that's what makes zero
sense it makes
no sense they were supposed to have
their time for the whole country to be
watching
the tv we're all watching this cnn was
on and they were counting the votes
and they were playing what the
republicans had to say and i was like
this is it
the chance for the american people to
hear the argument and then they
evacuated shut it down
and that was it and then nobody was
watching and i was really interested on
what josh hawley was going to come out
and say because i was actually
shocked that he came out and was like
i'm going to eject something okay this
is one of the more
rising stars of the the republican party
you know he's come out
and just set himself as a populist he's
um he also kind of set himself apart by
like working with bernie sanders on
on the 2k stimulus check but once he
came out i said okay this is going to
get interesting
even you know ted cruz followed then but
like you said everyone is now jumping
ship
uh you know laughter ended up rescinding
her her objection as well and
it's going all downhill real real fast
for this situation
what's the reconciliation though is
there just none i mean
oh well i mean you got like ted cruz
saying let's put the anger aside and
come together
but they don't want it cnn clearly
doesn't want it aoc doesn't want it
the the jankyuger doesn't want it they
don't want it they do not want peace and
so the problem is they don't realize
or they do i don't know when they point
to like this q anon viking guy
this is not the majority of americans
let alone
trump's base or the republican party
it's just there are fringe people
uh you know i really don't like it when
the conservatives say that antifa is the
democratic party and i'm like come on
agreed exactly exactly but they do think
it's easier to overthrow a feeble old
man than a fascist that's what they've
been saying on social media
but they don't like joe biden and so
i've even been saying like now antifa
and the trump supporters are against the
establishment right but when you get
the the high-profile leftists claiming
that every person who voted for trump is
like a q a person and that's what they
do
you're creating very serious problems
and so they're like we don't want to
unify with these cute
crazy people and it's like okay what
about like the middle-aged suburban
housewife
who isn't all that political and just
vote a republican for the sake of
republican
you're gonna accuse her of being a
cultist are you going to blanket
everybody in the same group
well apparently that's why they don't
want to unify they don't want to be we
can't associate with them they have a
a hyper-polarized view of the other and
that's all we get in media all day every
day is the other is bad the other is bad
and i think the one thing that's unique
there as well
just in terms of the way that one side
is viewed from the other
i i don't think that i think that the
right might often say
in media you know the left is acting in
bad faith but they'll never
really like say you're ignorant or
you're stupid or you're somehow sub
smart enough to stand on the same plane
as me but having worked at nbc
and then worked at the daily caller and
for mark levin
i mean that's a very real thing and i
think it's really really really really
hard until you're on that side and you
experience it we've got some uh
partially breaking news from the past
hour shamari stone of
nbc says breaking them outside the u.s
capitol a police officer just walked by
with a flashlight shined it in our
parked suv in other parked cars
many officers holding assault rifles run
down constitution avenue
an officer just told me you might want
to clear the area now i'm going to issue
a correction for shimari
i don't believe they use assault rifles
do they or actually they're police they
might actually have selected
selective fire on these things right
yeah they have like fully auto usually
so they're assault rifles absolutely
okay so
it depends on the cop but but attack
police that are yeah
with full auto these are actual assault
rifles okay so that's my bad
he says he again a u.s capital peace
police officer just told me sir this is
an emergency situation clear the area
police hold assault rifles and search
cars well it i want to just
mention to tim before me and richie got
over here one of our reporters of the
daily caller was actually shooting some
beer at the capitol and he let us know
uh after 40 minutes that he was on the
ground that he he was cleared away from
the capitol because they were searching
for i believe a second bomb right rich
there's
oh just right now right now tonight this
is earlier today this is at uh yeah a
few hours ago
maybe 3 p.m yeah wow so that was yeah we
we i forgot to mention that as soon as
soon as we got in the show but yeah that
happened earlier today we had a daily
call reporter on the ground there
well i don't know what's going on now
something's happening i can't really
find anything but okay
let's keep an eye on it yeah this is
becoming the breaking news show tim yeah
right well
it happens it happens well that's good
it's important to cover these events now
another thing i wanted to add on your
comments about the fringe tim
is that the fringe is only going to grow
because of censorship more censorship
more people will go
on the fringe and the mainstream media
now saying we need to ban them more we
need to censor them more is going to
have the opposite effect people need to
realize that
and and another thing to kind of really
really kind of consider here
is uh the copycat effect uh because we
were just talking about mob and
mentality i think this is also something
important to consider
especially how the media many times
uh helps kind of spur on mayhem
especially with their coverage
of mass shooting events and this has
been criticized many times oh yeah
through many scientific studies showing
how highlighting and glorifying a
shooter during a big national event
only creates copycat shooters the
mainstream media knows about this the
scientists know about this anyone paying
attention knows about this
but yeah if we want to reduce harm
you're not going to create more fringe
people you're going to
going to actually address real issues
like the copycat effect that no one
really wants to even have a
legitimate conversation about that
legitimate cause that legitimately
causes pain and suffering you know
what's really funny is
andrew yang had some tweets where he
said that
media polarization is causing this
problem he talks about the issues that
have led to the hyperpolarization
and then he says partisan media and then
he puts in parentheses fox
and a lot of people were like why did
you need to do that you should not have
done that
he's right i think fox plays into it i
think steven plays into it i think msnbc
plays into it
there's just you know 10 10 news outlets
for every one fox
exactly but regardless when you get that
it creates a problem i've even
self-reflected on my own content where
i'm often critical of the democrats and
i'll say it right now
i can sit here and say oh the tribalism
is all bad and i'm heavily criticizing
aoc
how do you get past i don't think it's
possible if ted cruz says we need peace
i say thank you ted cruz when aoc says
no peace
expulsion i say okay that's a problem
that's exactly my point which is that
if you wanted to have somebody on this
show uh
who was you know left of center it would
be much harder than
i presume and and that is exactly what
i'm talking about which is
he's beneath me because he thinks this
you know because whatever he's not
establishment legacy
whatever it doesn't work for the new
york times it's just absolutism it's
authoritarian
pushing pushing the humanism and the
algorithm also specifically on twitter
promotes it
whenever you dunk on somebody or insult
someone the algorithm
is done in a way where more people see
that particular post
more people engage in that particular
post and you're seeing more followers
more likes more hearts
especially the more divisive you are and
we have to also i mean legitimately
point the finger at big tech social
media companies that have been
benefiting off of this tribalism warfare
that they've been breeding
they are partially responsible for it
and there's a lot of people talking
about all these conspiracies but this is
something legitimately
that we should worry about that we
should consider on on a big level
because
these are the ingredients that created
this situation
these ingredients are only being added
they're not being subtracted this big
pile of crap can't family friendly show
here but this big stinking peanut filled
piece of crap is there because of
specific
ingredients that are in there that could
be addressed but they're not
even simple conversations about them are
censored online and again we're never
going to deal with it
if we don't have free speech it's easier
for mark zuckerberg to ban trump
and then say oh it's for your own good
when in reality he's just saying i'm
more scared of the left than the right
so one of the biggest you look at the
things that led to
trump's victory you look at the things
now that are leading to the anger
and one of which has been censorship for
some time people not being allowed to
have a voice
when you take away people's even ability
to argue with you
well then they snap and they get angry
and so that was a driving factor and
and facebook and twitter and youtube and
twitch and snapchat
all these other platforms are like let's
spray down that is
you know the the we got we got this big
old pile of crap as luke said they
opened up a sewer line like let's
don't worry we're solving it we're
cleaning it up and you're like dude
you're just filling it up with
your phone is filling it up man thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go
live don't forget to subscribe hit the
like button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time